worked in whether attracting data
analysts at the start of.com era or
broadening the routes into Healthcare
professions these are always a challenge
we're bolstering teacher numbers through
the highest pay award for 30 years
providing generous bursaries worth up to
27 000 pounds and are leveling up
premium worth up to three thousand
pounds a year each year for the five
years for math physics chemistry and
Computing teachers that's Winter thank
you Mr Speaker the national Foundation
of Education research says today and I
quote a strategy for improving
Recruitment and Retention should involve
pay uplifts that are higher than pay
growth in The Wider labor market for
most or all teachers does the Secretary
of State agree and is it not the case
she cannot address this crisis until she
gives teachers and support staff the
fully funded inflation plus pay rise
they deserve thank you
I Thank The Honorable lady for for a
question in 2019 we actually launched
the government's first ever integrated
strategy to recruit and retrain more uh
teachers in schools and this had a
number of different strands in it
including supporting teachers on the way
in recruiting more various routes into
teaching and of course we have an
independent pay review body and this
year we did fully accept all of their
recommendations in full
so David Evan thank you Mr Speaker on
Friday morning I was privileged to
attend the Paulina School in Crawford in
my constituency to speak with teachers
and also to answer people's questions an
inspirational teacher as my right
unfriend knows is often the key to
opening opportunities to young people
for their future what more can the
government do to help retain more of
these good aspirational teachers
right
I Thank The Honorable my honorable
friend for his work and I'm sure like
many of us we have a our treat on a
Friday when we all get to go into our
fantastic schools and meet with lots of
children the early careers framework is
really focused it's just been introduced
actually last year and it's really
focused on trying to make sure that we
support teachers particularly in the
first five years to make sure that we
retain more teachers the figures show
that the risk of retention is actually
in the first
um you know to five years so we put a
lot of work and effort into making sure
that we support teachers more during
that period in Blackfoot
of course Recruitment and Retention of
teachers is important but all of us in
this house will prioritize keeping
school children safe from sexual
predators and I'm sure the minister will
be aware of the Scottish child abuse
inquiry detailing the horrific
allegations from a number of witnesses
to then to Edinburgh Academy and fitness
school by an individual referred to as
Edgar I have a number of constituents
who have complaints against Edgar this
man has admitted to inappropriate
behavior and is currently fighting
extradition from South Africa where he
has been publicly named that his
precedence in England with another
alleged abuser living in South Africa
whose extradition has been sought has
been publicly named We Now know that
there are dozens of boys who have come
forward to the police with allegations
against this man referred to as Edgar it
is important that others who were abused
by this man can come forward it is right
that his crimes against children are
named and it is also right that he is
now named it is for this reason Mr
Speaker that it is in the public
interest that the real name of Edgar
that is Ian Wares is now publicly known
well I Thank The Honorable gentleman a
child's sexual abuse is in abhorrent
crime and the government is sympathetic
to the victims and survivors of such
abuse as set out in November in response
to the final report of the independent
inquiry into child sexual abuse it is
important that due processes followed
allowing investigatory and legal
processes to take place in order to
maximize the chances of conviction
Philippe
to State confirmed that the government
is intending to raise starting salaries
for teachers to 30 000 pounds a year and
that the pension entitlement that
teachers enjoy is far higher than those
earning the same wage in the private
sector yeah uh yes my honorable friend
makes a very good point it was a
Manifesto commitment to raise the
starting salaries um it is 28 000 pound
this year and it will be 30 000 next
year from September next year in line
with our Manifesto commitment and yes I
can confirm that the teachers pension
contribution the employer's contribution
is
23.6 I think so it is a considerably
higher than many in the private sector
thank you Mr Speaker the secretary of
state says she wants to support teachers
particularly in the first five years and
the thirty thousand pounds a year is
kicking in next year but in London five
years is often about the time that
people have to move because they simply
cannot afford to rent privately or Buy
in the capital what is she doing to look
at this both in the immediate term and
in the long term to make sure that we
keep good teachers in London yeah
um well I think the honorable lady may
be aware but we do have a London waiting
for for teachers and but of course the
cost of accommodation in London I do
accept are extremely uh high in some
areas Lake Drummond thank you very much
to speak and it is indeed a treat to
visit schools and on Friday I visited
the brilliant horndine Technology
College where I was told that there are
20 ways of getting into teaching but
still schools are struggling to get
teachers so what more can we do to slim
down the those 20 ways which does seem
rather a lot and ensure that we have
well-qualified teachers to teach pupils
to a high standards
one of the main things we're doing I
think with mindful friend for her
question is to make sure that we have a
bursaries to attract teachers in
particular particularly those subjects
where there's a lot of competition for
those skills and I I actually am hoping
to actually increase the roots because
we are looking to have an apprenticeship
for teaching at undergraduate so that
people who won't need to earn and learn
can also be attracted into teaching
thank you Mr Speaker having dumped the
schools build the only education policy
this government seems to have is a
gimmick announcement on making maths
compulsory until 18. a plan that experts
say is unachievable in light of the
teacher recruitment crisis what
discussion did the Secretary of State
have with the Prime Minister before his
announcement because surely they told
him it was unworkable given that the
government has missed its recruitment
Target for Math teachers in each of the
last 10 years
so we have a very much a focus on on
making sure that our standards are very
high in school and making sure that our
children have the very best education so
that they compete globally when they
need to get into the workforce now if
you look at every other developed
economy pretty much all of them their
children do maths of some form up to the
age of 18 and we're a bit of an outlier
so what we're doing is looking to raise
the expectations and standards to make
sure that our children can compete and
also give them skills for life as well
with financial now of course we will
work with the sector and it is a a
long-term strategy to make sure that we
do have enough Maths for teachers we do
have a number of strategies already in
place because it is always tough to
recruit Mass features but that's why we
have introduced a bursary of up to 27
000 pounds for all maths teachers and
also many science teachers question
three Mr Speaker
with permission Mr Speaker I'll answer
questions three and ten together
all children no matter their special
educational need or disability deserve
the right support to be able to succeed
we will be publishing a full response to
the send AP green paper in an
improvement plan early this year and we
continue to work closely with children
families and Education Health Care and
local government sectors on this very
important issue hello MacArthur today is
Blue Monday and I'm sure both you Mr
Speaker and the education secretary will
be pleased to know that following the
event we did last year the band New
Order and the charity calm have teamed
up together today to urge people not to
hold back from seeking Health with their
mental health if they need it but as we
discussed at that event too many
children are facing unconscionable
delays in getting assessed and in
getting support too many children risk
being damaged for Life as a result so
can the minister please get a move on
and bring forward the response to the
send review consultation children
shouldn't have to wait any longer
I think there was a lady for a question
I can assure her will work incredibly
hard and we'll be publishing a response
imminently in the meantime we are
rolling out training on mental health
for all schools across the country and
I'm working very hard on my counterparts
for the health to make sure that when we
look at the proposals on send that they
are brought fully into the picture as
well David Johnson
I have many local parents in Oxfordshire
who are unhappy with the County Council
for a variety of reasons from emails
that are never answered to ehcps that
come back with details about the wrong
child on them or just long delays in
receiving the hcp my honorable friend
will know many parents want this as it's
become the only way to get support for
their children where they might have
been able to get support at an earlier
stage from school and that not be
necessary can she tell us what steps
she's taking to address this
well I know my honorable friend has
raised this issue with me several times
and one of the key parts of the reforms
that the sen green people will set out
is clear standards for what help
children with different send needs
should be getting in school because that
will give parents greater transparency
and accountability and what their child
should reasonably get but it also means
their children will get the early help
that my honorable friend so rightly
talks about
temperature
Mr Speaker she will be aware that Devon
Children's Services has been failing now
for many years with special educational
needs being a particular problem
following the latest inspectors Downing
report the County Council has belatedly
appointed a new head of tuition services
but will she make absolutely clear to
the political leadership of Devon County
Council that if things don't improve
quickly she will have no hesitation in
stripping Devon of its responsibility
for children's services
I Thank The Honorable gentleman for his
question we do work with all areas who
are struggling to provide scnd through
our regions group work or through our
delivering better value programs and our
safety valve programs so I will of
course look at this issue very carefully
and we always step in and act when we
need to
Mr Speaker one of the best ways that
young people with scnd can be support is
by remaining in the local area to be
educated that's why I'm delighted thanks
to a significant amount of government
investment that middlehurst school which
is currently sitting empty is now being
built to create 80 new scnd school
places will my honorable friends
congratulate councilor Janine Bridges
and so contain city council for this
amazing work and pleasure to come open
it when it's ready hopefully at the end
of this year yeah
but I will absolutely commend the work
of councilor Janine Bridges who sounds
like she's doing a tremendous job to
increase the number of places for snd
children and I'd be delighted to come in
and see whether I've been open as well
well I've been Walker question four
please Mr Speaker
I know how important Child Care is uh to
the chair and I look forward to seeing
his committee's report on this getting
this right is fundamentally important
for parents and children and my
honorable friend the minister for
children families and well-being is
looking at all options to improve the
cost flexibility and availability of
child care and crucially outcomes for
children it may interest the members
opposite that since 2010 we have doubled
Labor's offer from 15 hours to 30 hours
of free child care for three to four
year olds we've also introduced 15 hours
free child care a week for disadvantaged
two-year-olds and parents on Universal
Credit can claim back up to 85 percent
of their child care costs
well great it wasn't Secretary of State
for that answer and she's right to set
out what has been achieved but as she
will recognize the issue of access to
Affordable and high quality Child Care
is high on the agenda of parents and of
members right across this house and it's
something that as she's recognized as
select committee are looking into
there's been much speculation in for
media as to whether this remains a
priority for the government can she
reassure me and the committee that she
does plan further reform and investment
in this space
service day I thank my honorable friend
for his question and I can reassure him
and the whole house that child care is
important to this government I met with
the chief secretary to the treasury on
this actually only last week helping
Working Families to take up child care
and remaining work is a government
priority and we've also taken some steps
to make sure this happens and we also
want to make sure that people are going
to benefit from a lot of the schemes
that we have in place and some of them
are underutilized so we do have a 1.2
million pound Child Care choices
campaign to increase the usage of those
but we will go further and we are
looking at all options to improve the
affordability and availability of child
care and crucially outcomes for children
thank you Mr Speaker sadly Child Care is
not the only thing that parents are
struggling to afford to pay for and I'm
very grateful to Karen Taylor from
rooted in Hull for drawing to my
attention the work done by the child
poverty Action Group on poverty proofing
schools and what this does is provides a
toolkit for schools to look at their
Academic Year and to identify times when
they're asking parents to pay money and
then to try to find ways to alleviate
this and reduce the cost to parents so
will the secretary say join me in
encouraging many schools up and down the
country Academy chains and head teachers
to have a look at this toolkit and do
what they can to reduce the costs
associated with sending their child to
school yeah
I Thank The Honorable lady for her
question and of course we're always
focused on what more we can do we
obviously have people premium funding
but we also have school uniform guidance
obviously we have the highest number of
children benefiting from free School
meals as well and in deprived areas
breakfast clubs which we have introduced
but of course we all know that
economically times are tough which is
why we're very much focused on trying to
get inflation down and the prime
minister's pledge to halve inflation
this year children Minister hello
thank you Mr Speaker Child Care is
essential social infrastructure which
underpins our economy by supporting
parents to work yet in 2022 more than 5
000 child care providers closed and more
than half of all local Authority areas
saw a net loss of child care places the
government has admitted that they pay
providers less than it costs them to
deliver the so-called free child care
places and with energy bills and wages
going up from April many more providers
are at risk of closure there is a crisis
in our early years sector happening
right now what is the government going
to do to stop further child care
providers from closing yeah yeah
um but I think the honorable lady for a
question actually ofsted data shows that
the number of child care places
um has remained broadly stable at 1.3
million since August 2015. but at the
spending review uh 2021 we announced
additional funding of 160 million pounds
in 22 23 and 180 million pounds is 23 24
and 170 million pounds 24.25 and that's
compared to the 20 21 22 Financial year
and this will allow local authorities to
increase hourly rates paid to child care
providers you trolled us speaker number
five
we are transforming people's lives uh
life chances by enabling them to climb
the education skills ladder of
opportunity and on the 9th of January
this year we announced that in financial
Year 2023-24 we will increase funding
rates to invest a further 125 million
pounds in 16 to 19 education 18.5
million pounds in 16 to 19 education has
been invested in institutions that cover
the constituency of Waverly
but taking into account both the urgent
need to address cute skill shortage in
key sectors of the economy and the fact
that at participation in adult education
has fallen from 4.4 million in 2003 2004
to 1.5 million in 2019-2020 it is vital
that the capacity of further education
is significantly expanded my right
honorable Fender Chancellor highlighted
the importance of investment in skills
in his Autumn statement and I'll be
grateful if my arrival friend could set
out the work that has been done to meet
this challenge ahead of the spring
statement my honorable friend is an Fe
champion and I welcome his question and
he will be pleased to know that we're
investing in resources increasing skills
funding by 3.6 billion over this
Parliament investing in quality
qualifications like T levels higher
technical qualifications Free level
three courses bootcamp amps and
apprenticeships and investing in
infrastructure as well rolling out 21
institutive Technologies spending 290
million pounds
come on my old friend he can do better
than that the fact of the matter is
still further education in our country
is the Cinderella service when will you
wake up to the fact that we need more
skilled people in our country we need
them desperately and the Fe sector is
the one area that you could actually do
the real investment that pays back very
quickly
where can I urge the minister who I like
a lot we're old friends get his act
together and put some real heft into
further education
um when The Honorable gentleman
describes Ephesian Cinderella sector I
might to remind you that Cinderella
became a member of the royal family
and and it's this government it's it's
it's this government that is banishing
the two ugly sisters of under-resourcing
and snobbery about further education and
skills
uh
and as I said as I said to uh in my
previous answer to my honorable friend
we're investing a 3.6 extra because 3.6
billion extra uh in skills in this
Parliament 1.3.8 billion I should say
1.6 billion extra for uh Fe increasing
the number of hours students learn I'm
very proud of this government's approach
to further education and skills
right let us move to Shalom Mr Toby
Perkins
well uh thank you very much Mr Speaker I
mean the minister uh was a huge Champion
for the Fe sector um when he was the
select committee chair so it'll be
depressing to hear that he's now
speaking up for this government this
government's funding settlements for
referee colleges are the worst in
post-war history not my view the view of
the independent Institute Institute for
fiscal studies their analysis exposes
that per student funding fell 14 in real
terms between 2010 and 2019 isn't the
reality
that after 13 years of this government
it's only the election of a labor
government that will allow our colleges
to play the role we truly need from them
so say to my honorable friend uh it's
wishful thinking on his part I mean the
the government is increasing investment
in apprenticeships the 2.7 billion by
2025 425 we'll be investing an extra 1.6
billion in 16 to 19 education at the
same period of time that includes 500
million a year for T levels I mentioned
the 219 million pounds that's being
spent on Institute of Technology not
knowledge is and uh 1.5 billion pounds
to commit and upgrade uh Fe College of
State in England over the next few years
so this is a government that's investing
it's in championing further education
and skills and my honorable friend
should recognize that hello mistakes
Please Mr Speaker
as sat out in our send and alternative
provision green paper published in March
uh our ambitious alternative provision
reforms will keep all children in AP
with the right support in the right
setting at the right time our reforms
will enable children with behavior that
present barriers to learning or medical
needs to have the support skills and
confidence needed to thrive Rob Butler
thank you Mr Speaker and I'm grateful to
my honorable friend for that answer many
of the children I've met in the youth
justice system have been excluded from
mainstream schools and instead sent to
Alternative provision where often the
standards are very good but sadly that
is far from always the case indeed the
youth Justice board on which I used to
sit said an improvement in standards and
practices needed across alternative
provision so what action is the minister
taking to make sure that alternative
provision isn't a Dumping Ground for
difficult pupils that mainstream schools
want to exclude and that by contrast
it's high quality teaching and Welfare
support that is always the case in AP
Minister I thank my honorable friend I
know he's a passionate believer in youth
Justice in fact I think the first time
we met that's what we were speaking
about and he is right to be concerned
about this area we know there are some
great AP settings and did I was talking
to Mark Vickers of olive academies
recently but we know that some settings
are delivering very poor outcomes for
young people I really am excited about
our proposals on AP I think they will be
transformational I'll be happy to
discuss them further with the honorable
member Ford thank you Mr Speaker funding
for alternative provision for children
who are unwell Peter's out after the age
of 16. there was no mention in last
November's budget of of colleges I've
got a constituent in Devon whose mother
I spoke to this morning the sun has been
diagnosed with Hodgkin's lymphoma and is
unable to get the online tuition that he
needs from from our local college so I
wonder
when my colleges receive the additional
Revenue funding so that they might be
able to afford the alternative provision
for children diagnosed with illnesses
like my constituent
so as part of the reforms that we're
setting out we'll be developing a
bespoke national alternative framework
that will include looking at standards
looking at sustainable post-16
destinations and I'd be happy to discuss
with the honorable gentleman further
once we've published our proposals it's
early on part
Mr Speaker
with permission Mr Speaker answer
questions 7 and 22 together family hubs
are One-Stop shops that make it easier
for families to get the support they
need and I strongly support them the
government is investing 300 million
pounds in the start for life and family
hubs program and 75 local authorities
will begin to open hubs later this year
and you know that family hubs are a part
of the solution to many national and
local issues and are vitally leading
needed in many of our local communities
more now more than ever in addition to
the rollout of family herbs what steps
is my right honorable friend taking to
ensure that this fantastic policy has
long-term funding to maximize long-term
benefits
I think my honorable friend fair
question and I strongly agree with my
honorable friend we are funding 75
councils for the current spending review
period And I have no doubt that the
excellent work in East Sussex led by
Becky Shaw and her excellent team and
across the country will make the case
for further investment
thank you Mr Speaker I'm very proud of
the work this government is doing with
family hubs early years and start to
life and in Wales each seeking to give
babies and young children the very best
start to life in in Wales every
Community has a Kill made bathroom an
informal group of mothers babies and
young children it's a tradition almost
in Wales of care within the community
but the more formal support for the
early years is more variable across
Wales I wonder
does the minister could the minister
tell me what Arrangements there are for
sharing or exchanging these best
practices with the Welsh government on
important areas such as this
I think the unmanable friend for his
question and we do have regular meetings
actually with all of the devolved
authorities and we do share ideas as
well of what we're doing and different
policies so that we can learn from each
other and we can you know there's no
Monopoly on good ideas we're always open
to listening and sharing for basketball
Mr Speaker since the publication of the
independent reviewing to Children Social
Services which also will improve the use
of family hubs hundreds of children have
been taken into care while millions of
profit have been put out into the
private sector so when is she going to
publish the government's delayed
response to this review and will she
look at York being a pilot to ensure
that we can move this forward quickly
um well I thank the unrelated for the
question and I just want to assure that
this is work that we are my honorable
friend the minister for children's
families and wellbeing is is is working
very actively on and it will be
published very soon and I'm sure that
mountable friend will be happy to
discuss further how we will roll that
out and implement it Teresa bill is
question number eight Mr Speaker sir
maintain Nursery schools make an
invaluable contribution to improving the
lives of disadvantaged children we're
investing in additional 10 million
pounds into their supplementary funding
from 2324 taking the total around 70
million pounds and reforming the
distribution of this funding to make it
fairer ensuring all authorities would
maintain Nursery schools receive
supplementary funding can I warmly
welcome that extra funding because it
means that for the first time maintain
Nursery schools in Barnet get a share of
this supplementary funding so will she
join me in welcoming this funding and
will she Express her strong support for
the maintained Nursery School sector in
the future
well I thank my right honorable friend I
know she has consistently and
passionately campaigned for the
maintained Nursery School sector and I
agree they're doing an excellent job not
only in supporting some of the most
disadvantaged children but also in
sharing their expertise and knowledge
with other providers as well
speaker in my bath constituency Midfield
Rose the Midfield Road nursery was sadly
forced to close its doors Who start
staff shortage is the major reason why
they had to close and many nurseries in
bath faced similar problems and parents
struggle to find Alternatives what
advice would the minister give to
parents in bath who struggle to find a
nursery
well I Thank The Honorable lady for her
question we have actually in terms of
early years increased funding by about
half a billion pounds set out since 2021
I do agree that Workforce is an issue
and we're looking at recruitment
retention very carefully and we'll be
setting out as proposals as as and when
we can James Wilde number nine Please Mr
Speaker
with permission Mr Speaker
9 and 15 together in December I
announced a further 239 schools that
will benefit from large-scale rebuilding
and refurbishment projects as part of
our school rebuilding program which will
transform 500 schools across the country
I saw the huge impacts our investments
have in at Camden Court school where I
met Mr Heel a head teacher and his
students that were very excited at the
prospect of their new classrooms and
design and Tech and science labs Mr
Speaker as conservatives we're not only
investing in the next generation's
future but of that of generations to
come on top of this we have allocated
over 13 billion pounds to improve in
school buildings since 2015 including
1.8 billion pounds this year
thank you I welcome the recent edition
of the King Edward VII Academy to the
rebuilding program following the
inclusion of Smithton High School in an
earlier round and the new investment
that's coming to Northwest Norfolk
however can my honorable friend right on
my friend assure me that given
smithton's great two star listed status
and the complexity that that brings that
the funding for that school is protected
and will ministers meet me to ensure
that we get the heritage and other
permissions we need as rapidly as
possible
I think honorable friends whose question
my department is working closely with
Heritage and planning officers to ensure
that we can address the condition of
smithden high as quickly as possible
whilst recognizing recognizing the
listed status of the buildings we're
working on the project with historic
England and the 20th century society and
would be very happy to provide the
honorable member to meet with him and to
provide an update on
Progressive Mr Speaker in Hamden hasland
and we received the fantastic news just
before Christmas at heinburn Academy and
hasn't in high school will be included
in the next round of the school's
rebuilding program and I eagerly wear
the next round so schools in my patch
like the Hollins can apply can I write
honorable friend confirm whether
school's rebuilding program funding
could be used in conjunction with other
investment for initiatives that not only
benefit the school but the wider
Community as well yeah yeah
as a manual friend for an excellent
question and we do encourage schools to
play a positive role in their
communities which may with many choosing
to provide access to sports and other
facilities the school rebuilding program
directly commissions projects rather
than providing funding to schools so
we're feasible we include additional
facilities beyond the scope of a project
and if it's funded by the local trust or
the local Authority but we are
interested in making sure that school
facilities do benefit The Wider
Community Laurie Vance thank you Mr
Speaker the writing member for bogler
Regis visited Joseph Leckie and that
really helped I had a good meeting with
the heads of Joseph Leckie and bluecoat
Academy with my friend The Honorable
member for Worcester but they've still
lost out will the Secretary of State or
one of her ministers meet with me and
the heads of those two schools to find
out why on Earth they cannot be
successful in getting funding for these
vital repairs say
um I thank God lady for a question yes
we'd be very happy to to meet and
obviously there are some schools that
are disappointed that they didn't get
access to this funding but we have now
announced 400 schools uh so far but
there are still another hundred in
future rounds as well but we'll be very
happy to meet with her Claire Wilson
here Mr Speaker a school's week
investigation found at least
retained it's called Aero concrete and a
further 150 need further investigation
officials described the concrete as life
expired and liable to collapse which is
extremely alarming now NHS England says
that it will take until 2035 to remove
this Aero concrete from all our
hospitals will we be waiting as long as
that for our schools as well
I Thank The Honorable lady for a
question the government published
updated guidance on identifying and
managing reinforced um aerated concrete
last year in March 22 all schools were
asked to complete a questionnaire about
the knowledge of Iraq its presence in
their buildings and if they have it how
they're managing it where the presence
of Iraq is confirmed we help with those
schools with the appropriate technical
support and we are looking to make sure
that we continue that program
sir many schools and colleges are
already marked Holocaust Memorial Day
I've attended such a remembrance service
in Harlow college and this is all the
more important they work closely with
the Holocaust Memorial trust and the
Holocaust educational trust two
institutions that the government give
give support this is all the more
important given that there were 128
incidents of anti-Semitism in our higher
education institutions uh that's sadly
at an all-time high
to thank my honorable friend for that
answer can I ask him that in addition to
educating children about the Horrors
of the Holocaust and the second world
war can we also take the opportunity to
educate children about the tremendous
courage and bravery and sacrifices of
the righteous among nations
many people on the continent gave up
their lives to protect their Jewish
friends and neighbors and one example is
a member of my family Jan kavchinski his
wife Helena and their 13 year old
daughter Magdalena all shot by the
Germans for protecting and hiding their
Jewish friends and Neighbors on their
estate in Western Poland as well as
educating children about the misery of
the Holocaust we must give them
inspiration that many of our brothers
and sisters in occupied Europe gave the
ultimate sacrifice to protect friends
and neighbors of the Jewish faith yeah
yeah I'd have to say it's very moving to
hear of your family's experience and I
absolutely agree with my honorable
friend we must teach and remind people
that there were many righteous Gentiles
who suffered doing everything possible
to save Jews and if I can mention
another famous polish lady Irene sendler
who saved 2 000 Jewish children from the
Warsaw Ghetto news and there was
Remembered in a special exhibition in
Parliament in the Commons in 2018 of
which I was pleased to attend but my
honorable friend makes a really powerful
point and I'm sure schools up and down
the country will be listening to what he
says
what's your number 12 Mr Speaker
thank you
we're improving our quality in
apprenticeships to ofsted will be
inspecting every apprenticeship Provider
by 2025. all providers have been asked
to re-register with the Registrar of
providers we're intervening to help
apprentices and employers as well
Paul bulbs thank you Mr Speaker miss my
local College eastleigh college worked
alongside 700 Regional employers to
deliver high quality apprenticeships
right through to degree level last year
nearly a third of apprenticeship starts
were higher level so can I ask what
steps the government is taking to
broaden the routes into technical
education and increase the number of
higher level apprenticeship Stars
question he will be pleased to know
there have been over uh 10 800
apprenticeships starts in his
constituency since 2010 we're investing
2.7 billion pounds in apprenticeships by
uh 2025 we're spending uh some of that
eight million pounds on degree promoting
degree level apprenticeships we have a
big recruitment campaign fire it up to
try and encourage more apprentices where
transforming careers advice on
apprenticeships in schools in schools
and colleges and of course we pay
non-levy pair small businesses the vast
majority of their training costs when
they hire apprenticeships
okay question 13 Mr Speaker
thank you Mr Speaker the law is clear
that schools must prohibit the promotion
of partisan our political views and
should take steps to ensure the balanced
presentation of opposing views on
political issues when these are being
taught guidance to schools on political
impartiality was published in February
22 it summarizes the legal position and
makes it clear that steps taken to
ensure these legal Duties are met should
be reasonable and proportionate thank
you Mr Speaker you don't have to be a
historian to understand the dangers of
indoctrinating children and yet polling
by Hugo for policy exchange shows that
the majority of UK children are being
taught political ideology as fact in
school for example gender ideology which
states that children can be born in the
wrong body and men can have babies or
critical race theories that say race is
a social construct or sex positivity
such as in this document which instructs
children of teachers of children with
learning disabilities to simulate sexual
arousal on atomically correct dolls
while playing sexy music in class these
are not isolated incidents but endemic
in our schools the guidance is not
working what does the minister intend to
do about it
the guidance on a political and
partiality does make it very clear that
when teaching about sensitive political
issues relating to discrimination
teachers should be mindful to avoid
promoting partisan views or presented
presenting contested theories as fact
schools need to ensure that any
resources used in the classroom
particularly if they've been produced by
an external organization are
age-appropriate suitable and politically
impartial and schools should consult
parents and they should share lesson
materials when parents ask to see them
Mr Speaker
the government supports the provision of
nutritious food in schools which ensures
children are well nourished develop a
healthy eating habits and can
concentrate and learn 1.9 million pupils
are eligible for free School meals
that's an increase from 2021 when 1.7
million pupils were eligible in large
part of the increase is due to
protections put in place to support
families as they move to Universal
credits in addition of course 1.25
million pupils are eligible under the
universal infant free School Meal
program
thank you Mr Speaker each month four
million children experience food
insecurity going to bed hungry and then
setting off to school on an empty
stomach to tackle this Injustice my free
School meals for all bill would
guarantee that every child in England
would get a hot healthy meal each day
just as being done in Scotland and Wales
it could be paid for twice over by
removing the private schools 1.7 billion
pound tax break I moved at the party the
opposite blocked last week my bill is
due to get a second reading on Friday so
I asked the minister will he back my
bill or does he believe that
affecting tax breaks for elite private
schools is more important than feeding
hungry children yeah yeah well Mr
Speaker we the government has extended
uh free School meals to more groups of
children than any other government over
the past Century including labor
governments in that period so there was
no increase as I've said earlier from
1.7 million to 1.9 million there's an
extension to 85 000 students in Fe
colleges introduced by this government
and there's new eligibility for some
children of families with no recourse to
public funds and of course the 1.25
million children in infant schools again
another scheme introduced by this
government some peace first person Mr
Speaker the leveling up secretary said
in October the extending free School
Meal provision would be the most timely
effective and targeted of all public
health interventions that this
government could make
the Scottish government has already
committed to Universal free School meals
for primary children
does the minister agree with his
colleague and if not what targeted
interventions would he make to tackle
child hunger
uh we are spending 1.6 billion pounds a
year on free School meals for children
and we do want to make sure that those
that funding is targeted at the most
media and that's precisely what is
happening we accept the point and I
agree with the honorable lady that it is
important that children from
disadvantaged backgrounds children that
can't afford uh free lunch at lunch time
that they are provided but we are doing
so as I've said we've increased the
number of children eligible for free
School meals benefit related to free
School meals from 1.7 million to 1.9
million pupils
number 16 Please Mr Speaker
estate thank you Mr Speaker schools like
families and businesses across the world
are facing Global inflationary pressures
the Prime Minister has a pledged to
halve inflation and school funding will
increase by two billion pounds next year
as well as the year after that this will
be the highest real terms spending on
schools in history totaling 58.8 billion
pounds by
2024-25. in 2010 school funding stood at
35 billion pounds so we will be
delivering a 68 increase in cash terms
the government's also announced further
support for parents worth 26 billion
pounds next year Tom Mandy sundesi thank
you very much Mr Speaker in addition to
Great concerns about recruiting and
retaining teachers schools in slower and
across our country continue to struggle
with their budgets with a quarter of
primary school senior leaders reporting
that they have had to cut outings and
trips due to budgetary constraints so
Secretary of State how will the
government ensure that children do not
miss out on these vital to Opportunities
I like the humble gender of his question
the Autumn statement announced a
significant additional investment in
core schools funding the school's budget
will increase by two billion pounds as
I've just pointed out in 2023-24 and 24
25 that will be paid into schools
um bank accounts in April so I'm sure
that they'll welcome that additional
funding in labor thank you Mr Speaker
the department soon report now
reclassifies 17.
Mr speaker
thank you Mr Speaker two schools in
Northumberland are prioritized for the
school rebuilding program including
ringway Primary School in The Honorable
members constituency schools were
nominated by local authorities and
trusts and selected according to the
conditions condition of their buildings
following a robust assessment process
this is in addition to the 5.8 million
pounds of school condition allocation
funding for Northumberland County
Council in this financial year in
library thank you Mr Speaker the
Department's run report now we we
classifies a risk of school building
collapse and is is critical very urgent
and despite the Sterling efforts I've
had teachers and staff to keep school
buildings in decent conditions many
children in my constituency are taught
in buildings far below the standards
they should expect can the minister
despite what he's just say can the
minister tell the house when adequate
funding will be made readily available
to bring all schools in my constituency
up the scratch well we've allocated 13
billion pounds since 2015 on school
building and maintenance in May 2022 for
example the government announced the
outcome of the condition Improvement
fund bids for 2223 that will provide 500
million pounds for 1400 projects at 1100
schools and six forms the CIF is for
individual schools and the groups of
schools in addition 1.1 billion pounds
of school condition allocations was made
to local authorities and large groups of
academies we take this issue very
seriously we want to make sure that all
our schools are in the best possible
condition for pupils to be able to learn
number 18 Mr Speaker
my department has made a one-off three
allocation of funding to add 15 million
pounds to this year's student premium
Now worth 276 million pounds
universities can support disadvantaged
students by drawing on the student
premium and their own hardship funds
many universities like Newcastle or
thumb we have allocated funds to support
disadvantaged students
University students unions recent cost
of living crisis survey revealed at 41
of students have considered dropping out
due to financial pressures they're
trying to balance studying with part and
full-time jobs increasingly isolated and
exhausted and the Student Union food
bank which is restocked daily is emptied
quickly the record Being within seven
minutes now he knows that his additional
hardship fund works out I think 10
pounds per student and they're leaving
students of 1 500 pounds worse off
because of the mismanagement of
Maintenance loan so why are you
punishing students like that yeah yeah
of course I recognize that some students
are facing hardships with the cost of
living challenges like many people up
and down the the country the 276 million
pounds is a lot of money that
universities can draw and as I mentioned
it's an increase of 15 million pound
students in private accommodation you
can get a 400 pound rebate on their
energy bills with frozen tuition fees
for the past few years and there'll have
been frozen by 2024-25 for seven years
we've increased maximum loads and grants
by 2.8 percent and if students incomes
fall below a certain level they can
reapply to uh to get their loans looked
at and I really welcome that Newcastle
university has increased the package of
support available to students to more
than 1.7 million pounds
thank you Mr Speaker the cost of living
crisis we hear is serious for everyone
but for students in particular facing
real hardship they've just heard the
independent Economist estimate that many
students will be up to fifteen hundred
pounds worse off this year given the
government's current focus on maths can
the minister explain how his government
calculated an increase of just 2.8
percent in the maintenance loan
following 2.3 this year when the rolling
average inflation rate is running at
nine point three percent
I say to
um The Honorable gentleman that we had
to be fair to students and fair to the
taxpayer as well so we recognize student
hardship that's why we did increase the
uh the the the student premium to 276
Million by 15 million 15 million pounds
universities have their own hardship
funds I highlighted the 1.7 million
given by Newcastle University other
universes up and down the country are
helping disadvantaged students and I
mentioned that students whose Inc whose
family incomes before fall before
certain levels can reapply to other
student loans companies to get their
loans reassessed right we come to
topical's channel thank you Mr Speaker
and special educational number one sorry
service the
Mr Speaker given this is my first
education questions of 2023 I would like
to wish you the house and all working in
our education sector happy New Year and
share some of what was to come from my
department
later this month along with my honorable
friend The Children and Families
Minister I will be announcing our
comprehensive plans to reform children's
social care
soon after we will return to bring
forward our transformational Improvement
plans to support children with special
educational needs in February I hope
members will join me in celebrating
National apprenticeship week and in
April our schools will have something to
celebrate as they will be receiving
their funding which will include the
extra 2 billion pound uplift announced
at the order statement seeing overall
funding Rise by 15 in just two years we
are investing more in our schools than
ever before by 2024-25 it will be 58.8
billion pounds the highest real-time
spending in history
thank you Mr Speaker and special
educational needs provision in school
matters I have so many parents
contacting me because either they can't
access it or it's inadequate one family
with two newer diverse children
suffering from bullying and self-harming
found that their schools send policies
did not even mention autism or
neurodiversity so this morning the
minister said that the response to the
government's review would be published
imminently can she confirm that that is
in within the month and that the clear
standards that she measured will be and
that she mentioned clear standards can
she confirm they'll be enforced
um Thursday I thank uh The Honorable
lady for a question and it is very
important special educational needs is
something I take very seriously as does
the minister for children families and
well-being
um it will be very soon there was not
long to wait um and I'm sure that uh you
will be uh you will be delighted with
the Improvement plan that we will
publish which was early very early in
the new year and not long to wait Duncan
Baker thank you Mr Speaker uh my
constituent uh Haley Turner in our
community of North Norfolk is an
inspirational campaigner for special
educational uh needs uh to improve it
enormously across our whole area the
evidence shows that early diagnosis and
indeed autism interventions is Paramount
to uh ensure that children get the help
that they need and Haley now uses her
experience to help many others in the
community can I ask the minister just
what the government is doing to help
with neurodevelopmental services and
also to recruit education suggests that
you do know it is a topic if you can't
describe or not and we've got to get
through for everyone else's sake
yeah
so I commend your constituent Haley for
the work that she does I do think access
ible psychologist is Paramount so you
can get that early diagnosis and we are
funding an additional 600 223 400 in the
year after
right let's come to show Secretary of
the Chipmunks
thank you Mr Speaker the department for
education has raised the risk of school
buildings collapsing to critical very
likely and in December the schools
Minister undertook to publish the data
on these dangerous buildings by the end
of the year yet parents staff and pupils
are still in the dark when will the
Secretary of State finally publish this
data and own up to the extent of her own
failure
as we said I said earlier we're spending
13 billion pounds on Capital funding in
the school system since uh 2015 we take
the safety of schools very seriously as
I said as the Secretary State said
earlier uh regarding uh reinforced
autoclave aerated concrete we are we
have written to all schools asking them
to complete a questionnaire in terms of
publishing the data the department has
already published summary findings from
the condition data collection and we
plan to publish at more uh detailed data
shortly the condition data collections
help us to understand the conditional
scores and we will publish as and when
and the data is ready second question
thank you Mr Speaker no answer even
though the schools Minister said we
would see this data last year Mr Speaker
conservative members opposite have
described their child care policy as
crazy unnecessarily expensive and that
they should get on with reforming it Mr
Speaker I agree that's why the next
Labor government will deliver a modern
child care system from the end of
Parental leave to the end of primary
school if either wrong colleagues can
see the case for change why can't the
Secretary of State yeah yeah well I
think uh The Honorable lady will find
that when labor were in power for 30
years they did nothing on this issue it
actually
[Applause]
at the two-year-old offer and the three
and four-year-old offer for parents and
I would love to see the costings of her
proposals because I think what she's
proposing is yet More Pie in the Sky for
parents but we take this issue very
seriously we're very committed to
increasing the flexibility and
affordability of child care for parents
in this country Chloe Smith Mr Speaker I
welcome Secretary of State's brief
update just now on the scnd green paper
it's right to get the correct support to
families and to young people as early as
possible but the green paper was also
right to talk about a truly inclusive
education system what progress will the
9 000 young people in Norfolk with
Education Health and Care plans see in
2023
well I Thank The Honorable lady and I
hope that the 9 000 children will see
progress not only have we increase the
overall funding by about 50 for scnd
since 2019 where we're increasing the
number of specialist School places and
in the reforms that we're setting out
we'll be setting out national standards
which I hope will also improve their
educational experience SMP spokesperson
Carol model thank you Mr Speaker and as
a former teacher I support the right of
our teachers to strike and will oppose
the governments and strike legislation
so does the Secretary of State agree
that constructive dialogue with our
dedicated teachers is vital rather than
demonizing them as Bolsheviks and comeys
as one of her colleagues has
disgracefully done
I Thank The Honorable lady for a
question I always believe in
constructive dialogue I uh the very
first meeting I took as a we welcomed in
the new year was with all the four main
teaching unions and I will also be
meeting them again later on this week
if we are leveling up and trying to
recruit and train more teachers in the
Northeast why on Earth has the
outstanding Carmel College in my
constituency being stripped of its
accreditation to Trend teachers by a
tick box form-filling exercise
destroying 20 years of hard work and
leaving the Northeast worse off
well I visited Carmel College I know
what a good school it is
um the ITT the the latitude reforms are
a key part of the government's
commitment to leveling up and ensuring
that high quality teachers are there for
every child following an expert review a
robust accreditation process was
undertaken to him to approve 179
providers covering all regions including
the Northeast and ICT provision is also
expanding through the partnership now I
know my older friend met uh discussed
this with my predecessor The Honorable
member for Stoke North and I'd be happy
to meet him again to discuss my honor
friends concerns Stephanie Petco thank
you Mr Speaker and myself and the member
for Barnsley Central last week held a
meeting with parents about s e n d
provision Barnsley has one of the
highest numbers that EHC plans in the
country what resources will the
government commit to ensure provision is
improved where it is needed most
well I Thank The Honorable lady and I
can tell her that the high needs funding
for Barnsley increased 12 year on year
for 2023-24 which will be over 40
million pounds in total they also
receive 7 million pounds for hainese
provision capital from 2023 to 2025 to
increase number places as well Mr
Speaker I remind the house of my members
entry I'm glad to hear that the John
social care review response from the
government is going to come out shortly
and the governor set up an
implementation board to progress its
findings over 80 percent of children in
care are in the care of the independent
sector and yet that implementation board
has refused to allow any representative
from the Independent sector on that
board why not
all right
thank you memorable friend for his um
for his question I'm committed to reform
in children's social care across all
sectors and my right-handled my
honorable friend the minister for
children families and well-being has
been working hard in partnership with
the national implementation board and
the wider sector to design a plan for
reform that will introduce meaningful
change for Children and Families it is
quite a small group so we've
deliberately kept it small but I'll ask
my honorable friend to take a look and
check that it's representative thank you
Mr Speaker the number of PE teachers has
followed by nearly 3 000 in the last 10
years and the number of hours of PE
taught followed by 36 000 with nearly a
third of young people currently classes
inactive what's the government going to
do to stop physical activity flatlining
and make sure that young people can get
the benefits of social physical mental
benefits of PE in schools yeah well
actually we've met the target for PE
teacher recruitment for for most of the
last uh 10 years and we have the school
action uh School Sport and action plan
in place there's a new plan being worked
on at the moment we take sport in
schools very seriously it's important
for for both for physical health and
mental health and actually for academic
attainment thank you Mr Speaker parents
of children with special educational
needs who they are constantly battling
to be heard and so their children can
leave lead fulfilling lives some Stroud
children are only getting a few hours of
schooling each week which is hugely
hugely disruptive for family and child
so I'm working with gloucestershire
County councils Phil Robinson to improve
day-to-day experiences of Stroud
families but what is my honorable friend
doing to ensure that the local
authorities and parents are really key
to implementing the new reform well I
thank my honorable lady I am really
exercised about this issue I speak to
parents and children with scnd all the
time and I do think they find the
experience very adversarial I'll be
sending out more details in the
implementation strategy shortly but this
is something that I care very
passionately about Sean Hodgson thank
you Mr Speaker the current national
school breakfast program only reaches
one quarter of the children living in
areas with high levels of deprivation in
England labor has set out our
universal-free breakfast offer meaning
no child is too hungry to learn when
will the government join the labor party
in this commitment
we are spending uh 30 million pounds
between 2021 and 2024 on the school
breakfast program it offers free
breakfast to Children disadvantaged
areas supporting their attainment and
Arenas to learn are the focus of the
breakfast provision has been to Target
the most disadvantaged areas of the
country and that has been our strategy
thank you very much Mr Speaker does the
Secretary of State think that it is
acceptable that four out of five
dyslexic children still leave school not
identified and that teachers still do
not have to be trained to support
dyslexic children specifically I it was
a pleasure to meet the minister last
week but will she ensure that in future
early intervention is put in place for
the identification of Dyslexia and other
neurodivergent conditions well I thank
my right honorable friend and for his
collaborative approach in the meeting
that we had last week I absolutely do
think that early identification is key
and we'd be looking very carefully at
that anti training in the implementation
plan that I'll be setting out shortly
thank you Mr Speaker on New Year's Eve
the Care Community lost a highly
respected and dear friend and true
advocate Ian Dixon spent his entire life
making a difference to children in care
and urging governments to listen to them
the care review does not have all the
answers so will the minister please
implement the recommendations from the
pioneering care experience conference
for which Ian played a leading role in
well I thank my honorable lady and I I
paid tribute to Ian's work and I would
love to to look at that in more detail
and speak to her further about what we
can take forward
homes
the latest for me was children Academy
and talking to them about their grow
well support and we'd all talk about
funding but the biggest thing that they
did with me with on funding is not just
the amount but it's also the visibility
and the extended timelines that it's
there can the minister please explain
what can be done to make sure that the
schools know earlier and for longer what
money they'll have available
well I understand and agree with my
honorable friend about the importance of
a certainty over funding the dedicated
School grant allocations for 2324 were
published in December 2022 including
indicative allocations for the
mainstream school's additional Grant
which will distribute the additional 2
billion pounds of funding that was
announced in the Autumn statement
the additional 15 million pounds
hardship for students announced last
week amounts to less than 10 pounds per
head uh significantly less according to
my sums while the ifs says that students
are 1500 pounds a year worse off today
the appg for students is launching an
inquiry into the impact of the cost of
living crisis on students inviting
submissions from students so unions and
institutions across the UK will the
minister agree to meet with us to
consider the evidence we receive yeah of
course I I would be delighted to me 276
million along with other measures that
come down including the Energy rebates
and other support that we try and give
students who are facing cost of living
challenges so in life the government's
new emphasis on numeracy in schools can
I make a plea that the government does
not forget about literacy in schools and
in particular how we can continue to
raise standards I have an initiative
called get wooden reading which has been
running for 10 years now and I would
urge members of the front bench should
come to Witham to see that scheme in
action this year to see how it's raised
standards in education yeah well I
couldn't agree more with my right
honorable friend and I share her passion
I'd be delighted to come and see the
scheme in place in in high constituency
we take reading very seriously we have
risen through the international league
tables from joint 10 to join eighth in
the polls study and it's the least able
children who are improving fastest in in
those surveys
thank you Mr Speaker James kerfel the
head teacher a bloody senior Academy
which serves constituents of of my patch
let's introduced free School meals for
all pupils why doesn't the minister do
the same
yeah well as I said we're spending 1.6
billion pounds each year on free School
meals targeted at the the most
disadvantaged children but of course
schools are able to use their pupil
premium funding which is a two and a
half billion pounds a year to schools if
they wish to extend uh the coverage of
free School meals to more pupils we did
extend as I've said earlier free
scrimmers to all pupils in infant
schools and that was an early decision
of the Coalition that conservative-led
coalition government Jerome
speaker Children's Services in Norfolk
have been judges requiring improvements
all the way back since 2008. so will my
honorable friend join me in
congratulating executive director Sarah
Tuff and all her staff as well as
councilor John Fisher on last week's
assessment that norfolk's children's
services are now good and well on their
way to outstanding
um I thank my honorable friend I will
indeed congratulate that team it is
actually quite a hard thing to do and I
think it's brilliant that they've been
able to get to that that recommendation
Mr Speaker we take the safety of schools
very seriously The Minister's response
to an earlier questions so will
ministers reconsider mandating the
fitting of sprinkles in new build
schools to minimize the risk posed by
fires to the buildings equipment pupil
school work and the people within them
well The Honorable lady will know that
there is revised guidance to uh the
build the new building buildings
bulletin has been issued after a wide
consultation and that it does make some
changes to the requirements for when
sprinklers are to be installed in
schools particularly when the risk
factor of the pupils the students in the
school is high for example children with
special educational needs or residential
schools final question Nicki
speaker when I met with Jewish students
studying in universities in my
constituency I was appalled to learn of
the anti-Semitism that they have to
suffer on a daily basis often and it
made worse by the recent report into the
nus national Union of students handling
and challenging of anti-Semitism in the
month where we Mark Holocaust Memorial
Day I would be interested to hear The
Minister's assessment of that nus report
for her question I've been shocked and
sobered by reading this report the nus
has was in essence a hostile place for
Jewish students that's not acceptable
um nus Nation student the main body for
students should be a place that isn't
just safe at a place that is welcoming
for Jewish students as well and the
proof of the pudding of this report will
be in the eating I expect to see the
changes and the recommendations
implemented in full and once that has
occurred then I will re-engage with the
national Union of students
right that completes questions we're now
going to go on to the statement to let
the house clear
all right let's just come to the
statement I call the foreign secretary
James Beverly
thank you Mr Speaker